what's up guys this conversation is with
elise colleen of stillmark she's a
bitcoin venture capitalist and in it we
talk all about everything from
self-custody to mining what she's seeing
on the ground and where capital is
flowing in that ecosystem i really
enjoyed this conversation with elise and
i hope you guys enjoy it as well don't
forget that these episodes are brought
to you by ftx us you can click on the
link in the description to learn more
let's get in this episode with elise and
i hope that you guys enjoy it elise
i think you're here how are you
good morning how are you i'm doing
fantastic people are already upset there
doesn't appear to be a cat that is going
to make an appearance
there's not going to be today that that
is uh strike one
um what uh what are you most interested
in right now like as you look at the
bitcoin market obviously everyone seems
to want to talk about the price just
because it's being somewhat volatile and
there's uncertainty of the future uh
that's probably less interesting from
like what's being built
uh what are you seeing right now that
you're like man if people understood you
know this specific kind of theme they'd
be surprised
well there's a ton
on my side i think i'm having a lot of
conversations around mining
and the opportunities that will exist
for entrepreneurs and also just frankly
for people retail folks to participate
in mining and to acquire bitcoin through
mining rather than purchase and
we know that historically it's much more
efficient in terms of cost to acquire
bitcoin
via mining and so every cycle um i
promise myself that it's the year that
we're going to get you know friends and
family involved in mining and um every
time
you know we get too busy and then we
look back on the prior cycle and think
how silly it was that we didn't spend
more time and attention on figuring that
out but what i'm hopeful in this next
sort of batch of companies starting now
in the bear market and recession period
is that we see companies emerge that can
better facilitate retail's participation
in mining and who knows maybe in a
decade we see mining as
part of a diversified portfolio
even outside of folks that would
consider themselves hardcore bitcoiners
and when you start to think about mining
there seems to be a ton of conversation
around mining death spiral as there
always is in bear markets uh miners
selling their bitcoin that are publicly
traded uh how much of your focus is on
what i'll call like more
institutionalized or kind of commercial
mining versus the individual just buying
like a single machine and kind of
plugging in at their house or something
like that
right so of course we're working as a
generalist fund in the bitcoin space so
we invest across the board and some of
the pain points for minors are similar
for companies of all types and we're
seeing one now which is
you know effectiveness of treasury
management and planning
finances and planning for various
scenarios and treasury management and so
miners of course have been primarily
funded by debt
and as a result of the debt markets
drying up we see miners needing to sell
into a down market selling bgc
um but this isn't something new right
we've seen this in prior cycles and so
it's just something that we need to get
through and of course it also when
companies have financial pressures it
opens up new opportunity spaces right so
we're looking to see if there'll be
acquisition activity if there'll be
opportunities for new entrepreneurs to
come in and to do things more
efficiently or effectively or to serve
clients whether those be enterprise or
institutional grade clients or retail
folks better and so that's sort of you
know where it's early right we're kind
of we're sort of early into this um
this you know more like chaotic dynamic
in the mining space controlled chaos
and so we're just looking to see how
that shakes out and if there's
opportunities for innovation there
and when you see the mining businesses
themselves
uh obviously the oil and gas industry
the kind of energy producers outside of
bitcoin they've become major players uh
in a variety of different ways
everything from
down i think there's a houston oil and
gas kind of bitcoin mining like meetup
that goes on uh in that area all the way
to we've seen reports of some of the
major energy producers in the united
states maybe doing pilots i think it's
kind of how they've been framed as
they're kind of testing stuff out what
are you seeing there with like the
integration of what maybe you and i
would consider like bitcoin natives
people who are trying to build these
mining facilities with some of these
more kind of oil and gas or energy
native organizations
well you know it so it's interesting so
absolutely in the past couple months
we've seen a pro proliferation of uh
perhaps creativity in what sort of
energy sources and types can be applied
to mining and vice versa and so it's not
just oil and gas
or and it's not just you know standard
sort of um known sustainable sources
like wind and solar but we're seeing
everything from um
you know like compost materials um to
you know um like tires and you know all
sorts of um
materials that can be used to extract
energy from
and folks are are you know looking at
the um looking at the uh modeling the
scenarios to see if money can be made
there and of course
um when there's free energy there's an
ability to monetize that with mining and
so
folks on the energy side are i think
getting really smart they've gone up the
learning curve with bitcoin they know
that they can supplement um and add a
revenue stream to what they've already
built by introducing mining which can of
course as you know be done
intermittently
and so it's it's a great match for lots
of different um
modes of energy and i think that you
know people are making um a variety of
experiments right now and so i imagine
in 18 months time i'll have a lot more
information but it's really fun to see
the creativity um you know
entrepreneurial thinking that's
happening in the space including from
folks on the energy side that probably
have neither thought of themselves as
entrepreneurial or as
bitcoin native folks but bitcoin of
course is energy-backed money and so if
you're in energy you are
um you know soon to be if not already in
bitcoin and we're seeing that
realization happen
when you start to
look at the mining it seems like the
technology is also drastically improved
right i i yesterday i was talking about
mining and i was like man when i first
started messing around with mining s9s
were like the cream of the crop right
like that was the best hardware you
could get now i don't think i know a
single serious miner that uses those uh
because the technology has just uh
accelerated so quickly what are you
seeing on that front is that something
you guys are interested in investing in
is the actual like hardware or do you
stick uh mainly to more of the the
software on the investing side
this is a great question so a lot of
folks are curious about where venture
capital's focuses and what
arenas are a great fit so historically
my work has been focused on software and
that's not you know necessarily
differentiating for stillmark versus
other vc funds so vc investors
typically avoid hardware and focus on
software but
um that's not true for all and so if you
are developing hardware it's important i
think to find a an investor set that
understands the unit economics of that
the the different sort of financial
demands and
you know how to work with you to make
sure that your business is run most
efficiently so that you can grow at the
quickest
clip
now on the software side of course
things are very different when we're
talking about serving
a million people with software generally
we don't have to add many operating
costs to get from say 200 000 to a
million
the incremental cost of adding a new
user are very small when we're talking
about hardware excuse me we're talking
about software the opposite is true when
we're talking about hardware and so
they're pretty different businesses
but for stillmark on the mining side
there's there's starting to be more
abundance software opportunities
and so that's where we're really focused
not to the exclusion of looking at
opportunities for
proprietary mining or hosting or you
know the development of
new hardware we we could do those things
we'd probably want to do that with um a
partner on the hardware side meaning
someone inventor that had worked with
hardware investments before
but but more recently we've seen
software emerge to really have a
significant role in the mining space so
to give you a quick example of that this
is from the portfolio
we were we led the seed round for
satoshi energy which is a company that
matches renewable energy sustainable
energy projects wind and solar in texas
first to mining and so it adds a revenue
stream basically to projects that
have energy
available um when they're not selling
into the grid and so this is an example
of um you know a really great use of
bitcoin's intermittent nature
wind is abundant at night um
and we know that energy is energy
requirements are more present during the
day
um and so it's a great time to mine when
you have abundant energy that's not
called upon for other purposes and
satoshi energy is kind of trying to
build the bridge there and help energy
projects figure out how to best monetize
their resources so that's an example of
a software company in this space
and i'm hoping that we will find
others there's obviously opportunities
to allow people to sort of interpret um
how their hardware is working and to
optimize our hardware as an example
where software can fit in
um but there's and we've seen attempts
at matching um mining opportunities our
mining marketplace with retail
participants and so my hope is that this
continues to mature to
sort of advance the sector of mining and
that you know when there's a strong
software play we want to be right there
what about you pump have you invested um
in the mining space yet it sounds like
you have
a lot of people probably don't know um
that's how i got into a cryptocurrencies
actually started uh somebody pitched me
mining back in 2016. um and uh it wasn't
pitched from like the crypto angle of
like hey this is you know what uh
bitcoin or cryptocurrency or whatever it
was it was just like hey these are data
centers right and they were kind of
souped up
my family had a background data center
so i understood it decently well
and i started out mining with gpus
mining eth
and then
my
friend and partner jason williams
we started talking more about it and
started thinking about you know hey how
does this exactly work
and at the time he was the ceo of a
company called prti which uh is kind of
an off-grid vertically integrated power
producer so what they do is they take
used car tires uh they basically burned
it at really high heat uh in some uh
some technology an infrastructure that
they built and it produces uh oil uh gas
um carbon uh and um some other outputs
and then they're basically able to
produce power off the grid and so the uh
idea of the business originally was like
hey why don't we just go sell it back to
the grid and get paid you know whatever
it is three four cents uh per kilowatt
hour instead uh we ended up actually
building a uh a bitcoin mine there on
site to basically take that power uh and
just use kind of you you feed in the
tires you create power and then you
consume that power on site with uh with
bitcoin mining so it's fascinating
because
a lot of people i think that you know do
some sort of mining as like an
individual where it's not a business
they started it's very much like uh kind
of cloud computing like oh i sent some
money somewhere like somebody like got
the machines they maybe send me a
picture i can go online there's like a
dashboard but like you you don't see all
of the like operational complexities
that go into it and so uh i you know god
i don't know how much money was uh spent
slash wasted trying to figure out like
the air conditioning like how do you
keep the machines cool in the summer of
north carolina right uh how do you do
you know uh cable management how do you
actually uh ensure that things are
optimally uh optimally set up and what
was unique is that like i you know
i understood enough to be dangerous but
like by no means am i a electrical
engineer am i uh you know in any way
shape or form uh suited to uh to go
build one of these mining facilities
myself but because of the business in
the power production uh component uh
they had so many highly technical people
there who literally built a off-grid
power production facility uh they were
they're just geeking out they're like oh
we could do this and we could do this
like here's how you do and like you
really understood like kind of like go
to the metal and understand how these
machines work and so it was frankly more
than anything uh it was just a pure
education experience for me um and then
you realize like i don't i don't know
how big it wasn't you know huge uh
but there's like thousands of these
facilities hundreds of these facilities
around the world and that makes up you
know the bitcoin uh decentralized
network and so it's just like a really
cool experience um
and so is that is that center still um
mining it is um
the the idea is uh it's a great
kind of concept of like off-grid
vertically integrated power production
with uh the consumption of that power
not going to the grid but actually being
bitcoin mining uh one of the challenges
is that it's incredibly expensive to
build uh the off-grid power production
right you know
kind of low eight figures uh cost there
and so as they continue to do that part
of their plan is to continue to uh build
out these vertically integrated mines um
but but it's just a it's a capital game
and so i think what we're starting to
see now is like this is one of the
reasons why a lot of these miners are
saying hey we can go and like race
around the world and try to find you
know low-cost energy but you also know
what might be pretty cool why don't we
just go to the energy producers and be
like let's partner exactly right like
you guys got the energy we got the
machines and knowledge like let's come
together and you know we'll go be great
miners
yeah exact that's exactly right so
that's you know that's one of the
realizations that satoshi energy had
that that was something that you know
was going to exist is this sort of
really reciprocally beneficial um
healthy relationship and
um is there to sort of ease the pain
points of forming these new
relationships including sort of the
legal complexities of it um which i
imagine that you're also very familiar
with but it's great to hear that you got
into the space through mining
um and i sort of did so
you know one of the ways that i was
really pushed into bitcoin in 2013
was that i happened to
end up at a co-working space for
entrepreneurs to help one of our
portfolio companies at the time and i
was sitting next to a guy
that was mining like with a machine on
his desk and so that was 2013 and that i
did not start doing the exact same thing
as you know such a painful memory and i
i'm sure in 10 years i'm going to be
thinking the same thing that i don't
have you know like a whole facility set
up is probably
um you know a bad decision for sure but
i you know i was also sort of pushed
into the space um by the curiosity and
fun really of mining and so it's fun
it's nice that we share that same story
how are how are you thinking about
mining now have you seen
entrepreneurship um advance in the space
at all in a way that sort of
clicks with you given your operating
background yeah i mean i i
my general sense uh is that there will
be some you know kind of outliers that
like somebody can go build a great
mining business
from scratch and do it again uh my
biggest takeaway i think was just like
how capital intensive it is and so now
uh i kind of look at it as you either
need to have a significant technical
advantage so
did you create chips did you create some
asic did do you have some kind of power
production you know arbitrage like what
is the the technical advantage you have
that can't be replicated or uh closely
uh kind of followed by others uh the
second thing is you're a brand new
business but you just have immense
access to capital uh and you're able to
kind of bully the market a little bit
with that capital base uh or the third
thing and actually where i think a lot
of the value uh is going to accrue over
time uh is you either have a special
relationship or you have the backing of
uh one of the large energy producers
like you know if exxon mobil wants to
get in the game they are going to very
quickly become one of the largest miners
if not the largest miner in the world uh
and really the limiting factor there
ends up just being like how quickly can
they get enough hardware right but
they've got the energy they've got the
talent they've got the capital like they
have all the ingredients it's just they
don't produce the asics themselves and
so they're gonna have to figure out you
know what the solution there is and so
if you kind of run around the world
you're like okay cool you know you've
got exxon you've got some of these uh uh
businesses but then like what happens
when all of a sudden the middle east is
like you know what i got a great idea
what if we don't have to transport the
energy instead just like right here on
site we can go and like essentially
become you know owners of uh this brand
new digital you know ecosystem
it's gonna happen
yeah the competition will always be
around the cheapest source of energy
like just as you said technological
advancement or some sort of edge that
you have through proprietary technology
and then of course just simple today the
competition still exists around simple
operations and the professional
professionalization of mining i think is
just you know a few years old really
that's one of the opportunities actually
that block string saw you know that i'm
on the board of directors at blockstream
and blockstream has sort of built this
really um you know robust mining
operation that allows enterprise and
financial institutions to
host with them in a professional way and
you know these are sort of
really obvious opportunities in the
space that
you know
entrepreneurs are taking advantage of
like block stream did with enterprise
grade hosting satoshi energy has done in
this matching marketplace and data
insights um software provision and now
we're just you know we're starting to
see um new ideas percolating and so i
you know i'm hopeful that stillmark will
be able to
partner with entrepreneurs in this space
for sure i think there's still a ton of
opportunity
yeah for example when you're talking
about gas and oil large participants
coming into the space they're going to
need to find um you know the best
hardware it's not just about um you know
it's not just about access to hardware
and asics but a supply chain that you
know is robust and can scale with you
and is stable and dependable we know
that miners have you know had a problem
with that in the past and there's no
reason to expect that that will be any
different as um the hash rate grows
through the participation of larger
enterprise and so it's you know it's a
really dynamic space and probably
doesn't get enough attention and i
imagine that that will
um you know shift in the going forward
makes uh makes complete sense my last
question for you is around self-custody
uh how do you think about or how do you
talk to
entrepreneurs or even just people that
you know you talk to about bitcoin uh in
terms of um 100 self custody uh 80
percent self custody and then use
bitcoin on some of the the various
platforms whether they're yield
generation or uh there's some sort of
like regulated you know custody solution
like how do you just think about um
the i don't know i call it the dream
bitcoin like allocation uh from like a
custody standpoint
well that's an interesting question
because i think for us it seems like the
default answer to that question is that
companies want to
have 100
self-custody and with the exception
potentially with the exception of when
there's
known transactions or sort of like
reoccurring transactions that might
happen that required you know a simpler
experience
than multisig you know now provides
so self-custody has been you know it's
one of the conversations that comes up
in a bear market
people have time to sort of think about
how they're managing their treasuries
how they're securing their btc in the
treasury and of course individuals are
thinking about um you know sort of best
practices and how to prepare themselves
for the next bull market or even just
bitcoin's ongoing maturation and so
self-custody is generally the first
thing that people think of
and it comes up in conversation for me
quite frequently if people look at the
stillmark website they'll also they'll
often say we're using kaza for
self-custody um and that includes
businesses and so i think that you know
there's more businesses now like bitcoin
native businesses launching that know
that they want to include bitcoin in the
treasury as well as a responsible um you
know custody management solution and so
you know fortunately the state of zest
of that portion of the market has
matured to the point where
you know you have options you have
really good um opportunities to have
this easy experience of um managing your
bitcoin and being your own bank and so
you know i think that sort of just at
this point is table stakes for companies
that have bitcoin in the treasury is to
to have a self-custody solution that
works for the company and where your
business practices
are can be as consistent as the as the
technology itself and so what i mean by
that is just that the way that if you
have a multi-sig self-custody solution
the operating practice behind it
is known and is repeatable and is
something that can be maintained if
you're switching including executives or
switching out um and so it's not you
know what we like to see at stillmark
when we're looking at companies that
come to us and already have btc in the
treasury we like to see that there's a
secure self-custody solution in place
that includes multi-sig but on top of
that we like to see that there is
document a documented process of key
management and so that it's not
dependent on any one individual or even
a set of individuals it's just dependent
on a repeatable process and so that
would be i think an important part of
you know treasury management and
financial responsibility and you know of
course
we're seeing bitcoin founders really
sort of
get that and take that seriously
when you start
talking to newbies how do you get them
to try self-custody really we do a bunch
of work with ledger and i i just hammer
like make it easy make it easy how do
you reduce friction how do you get that
person who's like what the hell is self
because they never heard of this before
how do you get them to try like what do
you do
well you know so that is such a good
question i think i need to
um actually spend some cycles on this so
what we used to do frankly is wait for
coinbase to make a mistake
people to feel burned and then you get
them a ledger right or you help them on
board to cause that and some of the
mistakes you know i mean i think
you know or change a policy right
and so you know people
know what they want and expect from
coinbase
or from other sort of custody providers
and those rules are changing um and so
and and you know happen it's always
they've always sort of been in a state
of flux and so
for those of us that advocate for
self-custody and for the be your own
bank solution that bitcoin offers we you
know i think the time to really help
convert people is when there's a policy
shift that doesn't resonate with people
or feels off um and so that's what i did
in prior cycles and in the current cycle
i think what i'm hopeful for is that the
signal rises above sort of the noise of
the bull market and frankly that of you
know some altcoins and crypto spaces and
part of that signal should be around
self-custody and by the way when we're
talking about this we don't have to talk
about it as self-custody as multi-sig or
with using any technical terms i think
that you know we can sort of like meme
into existence be your own bank a bank
in your back pocket and sort of creating
a narrative that feels more approachable
and similar to
you know like the millennial experience
of a neo bank for example is a way for
bitcoin self-custody to really win here
which of course is a win for the end
user and the person holding the bitcoin
and then on top of that of course if
you're holding your own bitcoin there's
just more you can really do with it you
can get more use out of it utility and
so that's sort of the secondary
conversation to the self-custody um talk
yeah
palmer are you switching friends and
family over to um ledgers and other
self-custody solutions now that we have
some space in the bear market so i'm not
a believer that uh any strategy is 100
the only right thing right and i kind of
i kind of think of it like dollars right
uh most people have uh they have some
payment apps they've got a bank account
maybe they have multiple bank accounts
uh some of it they are investing like
there's a strategy of uh maybe not
pursuing decentral or uh pursuing
diversification for diversification's
sake but just naturally as you use
things and it has utility you end up
having different applications interfaces
use cases et cetera and
the way that i use bitcoin is very
similar to that so some of it is uh in
more secure kind of offline
manner some of it is in areas where it's
rehypothecated some of it is used uh to
make investments some of it is used uh
on an app like strike to be able to send
uh or receive with people like i end up
using it in different ways and so
when i think about that uh it goes back
to this idea of like
100
in one single thing
is probably not the way that most people
are going to interface with any asset
but specifically something that needs to
serve
as kind of this digital cache um
but what i do think is really important
is helping people understand like one of
the main value propositions of bitcoin
is the self-sovereignty aspect that you
know not your keys not your coin and so
whatever that percentage is for you and
everyone i think is different like
understanding how to do it and so the
way that i actually start with folks is
just like hey take five dollars worth of
bitcoin and just move it throughout the
ecosystem buy it on an exchange move it
into self-custody put it into uh you
know some one of these like a retirement
platforms then go buy another five
dollars move that into you know cold
store like just move it around and what
you will find out is like you're
learning and then hey you're gonna make
a mistake right and if you lose five
dollars like you'll be like god damn
that was stupid but like you lost five
bucks it's worth the education and so
that's actually where i usually start is
just like getting people to kind of try
to move it around
and one is like it's cool because
there's like an aha moment like oh wow
like it just moved like oh i see like i
did that right um and then the second
thing is like there is something cool
when uh people are like you mean to tell
me that like the bitcoin is in my
hardware wallet
and nobody like i'm not relying on
anybody you know yeah and they're like
that's badass right like there's this
element of like this is cool yeah
and people people get that once when
you're holding bitcoin yourself no one
can change the rules on you and so i
think that that's something very special
but you're absolutely right bitcoin
should be able to meet people where
they're at and in the ways that they
want to engage with it and so of course
we you know we all have um
10 bucks 20 bucks 100 bucks and our
lightning wallets um
but you know i think that the foundation
should be around the value and
possibilities of being your own bank
and being your own bank of course it
should include both a savings and a
checking account or something that feels
like that and so there's absolutely a
mix that can be had between you know a
ledger is another sort of self-custody
solution
a hot wallet and you know potentially a
third-party custodian but
when you're using the third-party
custodian you want to be doing so really
because you understand the trade-offs
and feel that you're benefiting from
that not because you feel locked in to
doing that because you can't be your
bank and so you know i hope that that's
another sort of um
you know message that becomes broader
more broadly understood in this
in this time where we have more more
opportunity to focus on signal and
education yeah i couldn't agree more
where can we send people to find you on
the internet or find out more about
stillmark
i'm on twitter at elise clean and
stillmark is stillmark.com and at
stillmark.com we have email links for
founders and also for other folks in the
community to reach out
awesome elise thank you so much for
joining us i always enjoy these
conversations and we'll definitely do it
again
thank you all right have a great day
you too all right everyone i really hope
that you enjoyed that episode i did
these episodes are brought to you by ftx
us you can go click on the link in the
description to learn more
ftx has super low trading fees sometimes
as much as 85 cheaper than any of their
competitors they also are introducing
digital stock trading to their
application what that means is you'll be
able to trade stocks right next to where
you trade cryptocurrencies those stocks
will come with no transaction fees and
no payment for order flow so you get
much better pricing
ftx continues to innovate in financial
markets and they are very quickly
becoming one of the most important
crypto exchanges in the world go check
them out by clicking on the link in the
description and go create an account ftx
today hope you enjoy these interviews
we'll be back with more soon